we're taking it to a completely 3d
virtual world
on your desktop but a 3d virtual world
that really brings
you know huge amounts of things that
does not exist in the 2d world
and then you know when covert is done
connecting that with the hybrid
connecting that with the physical world
this is going to be the
the real test for any platform out there
in my opinion
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford the way we manage events
has transformed multiple times over the
past few years
meet your own lipshitz ceo of all seated
your own leapchats ceo has led rapid
growth in all seeded for the past six
years
prior to that he was an investment
bankrupted morgan stanley
lehman brothers and reg crest capital
partners where he led scores of
strategic transactions in the high-tech
industry
jaron served in the 8200 unit and holds
a ba in economics and computer science
from tel aviv university
and an mba from carnegie mellon in his
spare time iran enjoys
skiing sailing and spending time with
his wife and four kids
if you think you knew how events are
going to be managed in the near future
well you should listen to this episode
ya ron lipschitz welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you today
i'm doing great nice to be here it's
wonderful seeing
you know you're on the other side of the
world it's sunny
are you in california now in the bay
area i am
i'm in the bay area yeah marine county
uh
a beautiful beautiful area i can't wait
to come to come back and
and sit down for a proper beer and do
this in person but for now
we'll settle for the zoom er now you've
become an
expert in this you know experiential
remote
interaction through all seated and the
wonderful things that i've
i've been following very closely hilo
fold is a great friend and ever since he
he came on board we've been talking a
lot about how excited he is about all
seated and
and i've just been wowed by saying you
know the awesome things that you're
doing
and so i love seeing this partnership
that you have but
your own journey is going to be just as
fascinating as all seated itself because
an investment banker you know turned in
then managing director of
red crest capital partners with an mba
from carnegie mellon
and a another degree from pelvic
university to turn
into an entrepreneur in the event space
in the interaction
people to people not the typical
investment banker attitude i would have
to say
so your own what gives who are you
who are you with all this stuff well now
that you put it like that
um i guess yeah my journey was very
different than probably most uh people
that end up where i do
where i ended up um i did uh
you know right after business school
become an investment banker i worked at
morgan stanley lehman
and then i was a partner at a boutique
investment banking here in the bay area
i always felt like doing something
different something that would be on the
you know building side and as most
things happen
uh i'm a big believer in serendipity by
the way this is a big part of our
platform sorry for the plug here but
a big believer in serendipity and things
happen in life the way
um sometimes you don't expect them to
and one of my really good friends from
tel aviv university
had reached out to me um i think it was
back
in uh 2014 and uh i haven't spoken to
them in a long time and he reached out
to me and said hey i'm going to be in
san francisco we haven't spoken 20 years
i'm going to be in san francisco let's
get together for coffee
all right great nice too nice to connect
with you know old friends
i think it plays nicely into this idea
that wherever you are in the world if
there's another israeli all of a sudden
you're best friends and you have to meet
i always find it fascinating exactly
exactly and so um daniel and
sandy shows up they show up here in san
francisco and we're having coffee and
talking about
the new startup that they're starting
and you know how cool that is and you
know events and
you know doing it differently and
collaboratively and visually and i'm
like wow this sounds really cool i mean
it's not a deal for me as a banker
because
you know i work with later stage
companies but hey you know here's my
buddy
and you know his business partner why
don't i just help them and pass the hat
and get the company some money to get
started right
and so that was kind of the the
beginning and then i found myself
getting drawn more and more into like
having those
conversations and you know bankers is
kind of a time management business you
really have to be very efficient with
your time
right i find myself spending time you
know with daniel
about investor decks and presentations
and what to say to investors and whatnot
and
at some point i get a whatsapp message
i'm kidding you know what i get a
whatsapp message from daniel saying
hey why don't you come and be the ceo
i'm like
ah okay i've never done that before i
don't know
i don't know what i'm you know i kind of
managed this but
i don't know what i'm gonna be doing it
don't worry you'll grow into it don't
worry about it it'll be fine
but there you go here's the story so i
went to my wife and i said listen i've
got this really
um interesting opportunity here um
interesting to say the least to be to
say the least yeah um
i could be part i could be the ceo of a
startup
and the company doesn't have any money
so initially of course
not only i'm not getting salary i have
to write the checks here and then even
when i do get
funded probably i'm gonna be making a
fraction of what i'm making now that
sounds like a great deal right
um she said awesome deal go for it and
that was that was it
wow so so you know i i just love hearing
those founders stories and
they're so authentic so many times you
know sometimes you do have the founders
who are saying okay let's just build a
business together whatever it is
we want to build a business but here
what i love and what i'm getting
inspired by is this
you're an investment banker you're not
even thinking about creating a startup
you're not even
thinking about the ceo position but
you're getting drawn into the people
you're getting drawn
into the into the industry you believe
in the problem
and and what is that problem that you
believe in what what is it about
the event space that you're sitting
there and saying huh
they're onto something i want to be part
of that something
yeah so i mean uh the background is that
daniel
um is a very very very talented tech guy
sandy has
uh tremendous background in the events
industry so that combination was great
to
start with and what i'm seeing is just a
very different approach to run events i
you know i got married as a i had a
remote wedding
and i remember the nightmares of just
visualizing it
uh planning the whole thing so the
problem is very different
as typically is the case when when i
joined and it was
hey you know you really have to uh put
stuff on the floor plan make sure that
it fits make sure that everyone is on
the same page
make sure that the logistics of the
seating chart the guest list all of that
is taken care of
and that was the initial problem that
you know when i joined uh
you know back in 2015 january of 2015
this was the problem that we set out to
solve that changed a couple of times and
you've actually
evolved a couple of times in a very
significant way
i'm i'm sure and and i can't even
imagine how much that evolved
like this in march of 2020 and i can't
wait to hear all about that
but before we get there if you look at
the timeline
of all seated you know from 2014 until
now
can you paint me sort of like the slope
of how you're growing as a ceo and
sort of like how you grew with the
company what are some of the big
milestones that you're like wow
these are moments that i'll forever
remember you know in my professional
career
sure um i think that the first one is
just you know
understanding what a startup is what is
it that you need to know what is you
know setting your goals very very
tactical what is it that you need to
accomplish
well the first thing that you need to do
in the startup is raise money how do you
raise money you know so i had it i was
fortunate enough to have
friends that that backed me and people
from my network and then vcs that
very quickly invested uh including magma
ventures
uh but but really it evolves into well
now we need to get
um some structure we need to get more
employees in the door we need to
uh worry about financial so you're very
very tactical initially
and then the next milestone was the
monetization we tried to do it one way
didn't really work we then moved to
another way and that worked great
uh from that point on the company was
doing you know this you know we were on
the sas model the company was
you know growing very very significantly
and so at that point you're really just
trying to manage
you know mrrs arrs manage you know your
cost of acquisition your your ltv and
all that kind of good stuff
as you leverage yourself as as a ceo
it's always
you you have to really reinvent yourself
probably every
six months or so and just deal with
complete set of different issues
right one of the things that i've grown
to be very inspired by
in this show particularly is i'm hearing
what i'm hearing is that a lot of the
times
as a ceo you do your job changes all the
time right every
way sometimes it's every day sometimes
it's every other week sometimes it's
every six months
because that's progress if your job
stays the same for the lifetime of your
company
you probably didn't do a very good job
as a ceo right
absolutely 100 and then sometimes the
changes
you know is uh you know
in conjunction with the inertia of the
company with what's going on the company
and sometimes as you
probably this is where you're heading
it's based on what happens in the market
and suddenly a completely hexagenic uh
exogenic event that happens and you're
like wow
let's do with that now so i learned a
new word exogenic but i'm
i'm and i think i understand what it
means so we we're at the nexogenic event
in march of 2020
the world changes and you're sitting
there and i can just imagine i don't
even know what
you were thinking but i'm imagining you
sitting there and saying like
there's a problem and there's an
opportunity
the um the visual of where i was sitting
was very very um clear i was sitting
at the last show that was an event
industry show called catersource i was
sitting there
uh literally on the floor having a board
meeting because i
i saw what was going on i mean i
literally walked the aisles and every
this was march 10th of 2020. i was
walking
down the aisles and every person that i
spoke to was like
all my events are getting canceled this
is a disaster one of them i
i will not forget one of them was in
tears saying i
am just so screwed right now
and i i you know having been you know in
a couple of those
uh you know that the dot-com and the
i knew that this was going to be
something unusual and i gathered the
board and i literally remember i was
sitting on the floor of cater source and
just basically having a plan
here's what we're gonna do and initially
you really had to play defense right
it's like
you just have to what's going on our
business could go down to zero
or it could be a huge opportunity what
do you do first
so you really have to kind of manage the
defense you know initial defense hey
let's just make sure that we're
we're gonna survive this and we're gonna
be okay and then go on the
full offense which is what we've done
you know about a month or two
into the into the pandemic so
do you know i mean because you don't you
also don't know how much to plan forward
to right you don't know whether this
is going to now wrote because i remember
in march i was still on campus and i
remember that we were
debating like is this going to be like a
two-month thing is this going to be a
full-on you know
year thing i don't think any of us even
expected it to roll into 2021
me being up at 4am in israel sitting
remotely with stanford so i can only
imagine
how far as a ceo you're sitting with
your board how far can you even plan
ahead
responsibly as you're thinking about
resources and the team and salaries and
board meetings and
all that stuff it was i would say there
was two things that really mattered
there was the tactical you know cash
flow right
what are we doing and we did scenarios
and we had a you know
very detailed plan with scenarios i
think you're absolutely right the first
one was well we're going to be done in
two months and then things will get back
to normal
the second one was with this this is
going to be through the end of the
summer
uh i think that the latest one that we
initially projected was september and
that was like all right this this has
got to stop by september
this will all be done we were wrong uh
but this was kind of the first
the first set of things that you need to
plan for as a ceo is cash flow because
this is really king
the second thing that we heard from
every single person in the industry and
this is kind of what
took us to the offense everyone started
talking about hybrid events
hybrid events hybrid events hybrid
events and that concept
is such a broad term
where it could be just you know i'm
streaming something from an event
and that's a hybrid event which is
really not to
kind of what we're doing which is you
know really providing
an experience at scale right you can now
bring a completely uh a complete
experience
into the virtual world that has the same
unified experience
as the physical event and that is really
kind of what the
the offense was and this is what we
where we shifted a lot of our resources
to i love the analogy of playing defense
and offense taking it
first being very intentional and
strategic taking the time and saying
okay how can we make sure that we're
well positioned
in terms of cash flow and our structure
to know that we're able to tackle this
and then once we do
let's flip on the switch and be on the
offense and and be a market leader
and figuring out how do we adapt to this
new world which is sort of hybrid it's
not really hybrid
we don't even know how you know i
remember that in march and april people
didn't even know how to
react to these new types of events like
you're literally inventing a new
customer behavior
that has never in the history of mankind
been tested before
it's not very common and i'll tell you
and
on top of that that behavior is still
changing
and will change significantly right when
kobe is hopefully gone very very soon
because the first events that happened
were all you know
something that really was zoom and and
just zoom and that's it then
it you know more 2d platforms evolved
and there was
a little bit more functionality we're
taking it to a completely
3d virtual world on your desktop but a
3d virtual world that really brings
you know huge amounts of things that
does not exist in the 2d world
and then you know when covert is done
connecting that with the hybrid
connecting that with the physical world
this is going to be the
the real test for any platform out there
in my opinion
right exactly because whoever planned
for an all and
all online platform is probably not
going to do the right thing long term
whoever plan for all physical is
probably not going to be that either
because
probably for every 10 people in an event
you're going to have 100 people that are
going to want to join
remotely and now you're thinking okay
like
how can we piece this puzzle and you're
at the junction right now we're
literally the point
where we're going to have this hybrid
model start it
start playing in in the world in front
of us right
100 i think that really if you think
about
um you know the gold rush of virtual you
know
platforms there is really a goal yeah
every day someone says
oh did you see this company you see that
company every day
most of them are you know i i you know
my hat is off to anyone that tries to do
something different and i
i don't say it in a negative way but i
think that when you're trying to connect
the physical to the virtual having the
experience of running you know our
platform ran
300 000 events in 2019 300 000 events
000 having you know having 300 000
events in 2019
yeah and and this was supposed to be
something like 600 the following year
if everything would have gone according
to plan so having that experience
you know the industry experience that
that very um
deep roots into the event into the
events industry into the different
players
the events industry is extremely complex
ecosystem you've got planners and venues
and caterers and vendors and
and a corporate client a social event
planet it's very complex if you don't
understand that
and all you think is about well i'm just
gonna solve this little problem and
ignore all the stuff on the side
it's going to be very very difficult for
you to succeed fortunately
we have those routes and and you know
we're building the platform with that in
mind
so how many people are working at all
seated right now
under your command we're set we we're 75
people today
so you're the ceo 75 people it is
march of 2021 and what we're saying here
is
you know the world is changing it's yet
to be determined how it's changing
and you have the fun and questionably
scary uh responsibility of you know
outlining what
should the vision be and unfortunately
you don't have the you don't have the
luxury of sitting
around waiting to see how customers will
will adapt to the world and then develop
it you have to make some choices
and you have to make them quickly how do
you even you know
think through making them i'm truly
curious about that because i would be
really scared
and really have a lot of fun at the same
time
it's it's very simple it's it's not it's
not a one person
it's a team and there is a lot of ideas
that come
and a lot of initiatives and a lot of
thoughts and and i think at the end of
the day
it's really if you have the team in
place that really knows
uh from the product side from the
industry side from
the marketing side from all of that
needs to come together somehow and i
i don't know that there is a scientific
uh formula for that
i don't even kind of i can't even trace
to see how that happened it's like
someone
attends a webinar another webinar it's
like oh hybrid events hybrid events and
then okay well maybe
you know we have a platform that really
already can visualize a
space we have a digital twin of a venue
already
we already are doing communication in it
well how about we stick some things and
you know this is an idea that we
spoke about in the past but now it's
like well let's try to do that and from
you know and now you have something
that's working within a month and it
looks amazing and then it's like oh wow
this is really cool
and it's just it's it's a lot of it is
is just um
you know sausage in the making that you
can really
scientifically trace so i think i think
the number one thing is really the team
and that that's what that's
from my perspective where all the credit
goes it's ideas
product industry and it's everything
from the team the second thing is to
have supportive investors and i think
that our investors are extremely
supportive of the company
uh through thick and thin and just you
know
having the ability to to go there and
say look we have this amazing new
opportunity we're now
changing the focus of the company
diverting it here's what we're thinking
go for it you know across the board i
think that that is also something that
you know many investors could say well
you know what just sell what you have
and i don't care about it
or just be in the bunker until the storm
goes away and let's not
double down here we had investors in in
any team that was re
really willing to not only double down
but i would say quadruple down and by
the way
we were not 75 people back in march we
were
about half of that we grew so rapidly in
the last six months because
because our our product is just on fire
it's it's a new thing and it's it's
i mean we so it was a little bit less of
a problem than you think it was only 40
people
elon uh i could go on for hours talking
about this and i'm i feel
so privileged to have had this
conversation now
literally a day after i went to the
street yesterday and
and people are sitting in a bar and
they're drinking beer and i'm
telling my girlfriend like i have no
idea what's happening i'm not used to
this
behavior and i'm realizing now very
slowly and quickly
how things are never going to be the
same and you know even if you know the
world attempts to go back to normal
everything is going to change especially
in your industry i can't think
maybe travel but the events
is the perfect example of a hybrid model
that forever will be
different no matter how you look at it
and i think it's just it's awesome i
have to say it's just really cool
thank you thank you so much michael and
at this point i i just want to thank you
for coming here i have the most
important question
for you which is three words you would
use to describe yourself
and again just thank you for taking time
out of your busy schedule to be here
i just love this conversation
um three words to describe myself i
would say um
family man it's one if i can use
two words to for one term there's a
hyphen would say
there's a hyphen right so it is one word
so family men
i would say um a friend
is the second one and and probably a
builder
uh as the third and that's a recent
thing so i still get to
i love it thank you very very much
best of luck i can't wait to follow all
seated i can't wait to see
how the product continues to evolve and
and how you continue to investigate
the new consumer behavior this is such
an exciting time i can't wait
to to start to do a case study on all
student hopefully when i go to business
school
and i think that it's just just pure
awesome so thank you very much for
coming here
awesome thank you so much michael it's
been a pleasure
take care
[Music]